salut et beauté et bat ça y est voilà on
en direct on est bien avec mes amis la
lia gilles verdez ya jimmy mohamed
pouvez nous poser toutes vos questions
les chéris je vous appellerai d'ici
alors il faut que vous sachiez que je
fais tout on en direct la sur ces 8
c'est historique 1 franchement voilà
donc je fais tous là je réalise d'ici
regard des géomètres un petit peu
l'envoyer sur gilles verdez et jimmy
mohamed lavoyer voilà la jv la voilà et
voilà voilà voilà voilà oui ça va dit
bonjour bonjour voila voila regard des
géomètres un gros plan sur gilbert
bécaud parreira voilà c'est pas mal ça
et je reviens sur moi qu'il est con mais
non messi mais pas comme ça on dirait
qu'il va sauter on dirait que tu vas
faire de la nage oui vazimba prends ton
micro élections comme ça là il est
comment tu le trouves la ridicule
ridicule mais non on va faire un tour tu
peux nous reviendrons alors jean lavabre
à courir tant cours de seconde et
urbains hors paris
il sera possible les cons les ce qu'elle
décrit c'est plutôt inquiétant et je
pense que là elle a besoin d'un contact
médical
donc là il faut qu'elle appelle le 15 a
effectivement si elle est essoufflé ce
n'est pas normal d'être essoufflé au
repos et sain une des complications
qu'on craint encore navires us donc oui
lorsque vous avez l'essoufflement c'est
le moment d'appeler le 15 et le médecin
évaluera déjà rien qu'au son de votre
voix
si vous êtes vraiment essoufflé d'accord
donc c'est allé vite et gilles on va
voir qui en reprend ton micro mon chéri
alors en pleine forme
non franchement ça va rater un garde et
qui m'appelle c'est bouder tient à
boubers bouder bouder bouder en face
time regardez comme il est beau celui-ci
savamment bouder mais tu as bien fait
elle encore en âge vous dit si vous
voulez lutter contre le coran a virus le
tajine sa maman chérie bas on est là on
bouge pas avant dit elle la gare a dit
blake de bouder vas-y mon chéri dans une
procédure de droit et louis il voit une
bosse qui magnifique s'approche des 10
danses à côté d'albi sens qu'elle a une
odeur répugnante et lui dit excusez moi
madame seward parfois l usine et le
parfum s appelle les trois s'étaient pas
vérifié crois que bon
je la donne est claire elle est mal il
ya plein de gens qui m'appellent ya
franck dubosc regarder mon nom du boss
qui m'appelle en face time regarder ces
mots francky ça va mon chéri d'amour est
ce qu'on le voit franck là à l'antenne
tendez à toi toi je vais à temps parce
que c'est moi qui fais la réalisation
donc voilà donc j'y vais voilà donc
callas franck dubosc est ce qu'on le
voit mon chéri voilà mon franck dubosc
là qui nous voient voilà ça va ça va mon
franck tu as une mauvaise connexion
ça va mon chéri tu me voilà tu as comme
vous le voyez leur frein franco et voilà
c'est franck dubosc pour chérie tu as
une questions à nous poser mon franc qui
met déjà qu'ils aient su fout dehors toi
oui toi tu as tu es chez toi dehors on
voit ça va d'accord très bien dis moi
mon chéri tu as une question alors c'est
qu'il va question attends attends mon
franc qui attend va te répondre moi
chérie je mets sur jimmy mois m alors la
question de franck dubosc on la rappelle
oui mais il se demande si si quelqu'un
est malade à la maison qu'est ce qu'on
fait pour les autres pour est vrai que
les autres tombent malades on nous dit
c'est hyper contagieux il faut être
honnête dans la cellule familiale
si quelqu'un est malade il y a une
immense probabilité qu'on la trappe
surtout si c'est les enfants parce que
malgré tous les enfants autant entre
adultes on peut se mettre en quarantaine
mais les enfants malgré tout va
continuer de s'en occuper d'accord
attendez attendez approche commune sur
moi parce que tu en as temps j'ai voulu
y est bon et lee savoir pourquoi les
gens achètent du pq non mais c'est vrai
après oui
non mais tu as raison alors est ce que
vous avez à la riponne data est ce que
tu as la réponse gilles verdez à 500
attend d'eux monde attends je vais
communiquer sur toi parce que je réalise
aussi des missions
alors pourquoi c'est la question
mais moi je donne mon cas j'en ai acheté
7 paquet j'ai acheté 42 rouleau de pq
que j'ai entreposés parce qu'il ya une
sorte de peur qui est impalpable de se
dire je vais aller y est je n'aurai pas
de papiers mais frais sans papiers je
serai là on a deux doigts de mourir
et toi ton principales provinces et si
je le comprends mais on va attendre
oui mais je reconnais mais je ne suis
pas le seul c'est pour ça que les gens
se sont précipités
est ce que cette part oui parce que sa
réponse varie alors et risio de très
bons scores dans un confinement et dix
ans tu te fais pas trop chier ah bah
ouais là là et en plus il adore jardiner
lui arrache peux vous dire lui tu as
d'une pelle et râteau il te fait des
merveilles
es tu serais content modéliste fort mon
chéri et comme on dit regarder pourquoi
pourquoi on a plein de stars aussi
qu'ils nous appellent parce que c'est
pour vous montrer
restez chez vous voyez voilà elie semoun
moins chez les jeunes il est chez lui mi
clos et aux licences chez eux ça patrick
bruel et line chez lui ferrari habitant
au monde à niary que j'aime
voilà rica en confinement mon chéri non
jure c'est vrai mais c'est vrai ça fait
vachement ces parcelles du met frérot et
je le dis à ceux qui sont chez eux
on va avoir des têtes si ça dure 45
jours préfères tu fait que manger
hier s'est défoncé trois boîtes de
chocolat
sur la tête de ma mère faire j'ai dit
ouais ouais surtout siège voilà on le
dit donc on s'appelle voilà je vous
dirais big folie vous savez quoi
une fois que tout cela sera passée ben
on fera un truc avec eux énorme voilà et
on invitera tout le monde on fera une
offre à une fête douves
voilà mes chéris ok je me réserve
individuel invs a dit allez vas-y une
petite blague vas-y vas-y vas-y [ __ ]
c'est sa mère mais c'est pas mal
t'inquiète pas il faut tenter des trucs
à tenter des trucs on est bien on est en
direct le shérif et vous savez que vous
êtes ça va mon chéri ça va frérot où tu
es tu es en confinement ester costarigot
baba est ce que tu es en race raoult est
ce que ça va ouais je suis en contact
avec ma famille c'est bien donc tu les
vois pas tu t en juste en contact dans
les contacts
tant que les contacts voilà c'est ça
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais et
et c'est vrai qu'il ya tous les gens qui
sont chez eux et ça fait du bien de voir
voilà que gad aussi est cheminot si on
est chez nous personne ne sort restez
chez vous moins c'est ce qu'ils ont dit
il faut rester chez soi sans vraiment
combattre c'est un truc de ouf qui
arrive frérot tu prépares ton prochain
spectacle toi donc c'est vrai que ça
peut faire plein de potes à toi qui
l'ont été sur scène qui ont dû à arrêter
leur spectacle tout ça c'est une place
pour tout le monde mais c'est vrai que
comme on disait avec matthieu delormeau
et gilles verdez me dorion s'en [ __ ]
tous à nous ce qu'on a envie on se dit
est ce qu'on va survivre est ce qu'on va
être bien demain est ce qu'on va trouver
des solutions pour que les gens puissent
voilà il est plus
et les plus touchées survivent tu parles
d'un au micro tu l'as eu ton papa là
depuis la fois depuis depuis la crise on
est fâché je n'ai pas pris de nouvelle
non non m'attendais franchement là ça
dépasse la fâcherie mathieu nord
matthieu frangins chérie tu sais que je
t'aime énormément c'est vrai ça m'a
franchement à webo que tu appelles ton
papa ouais mais même hors antenne tu
veux voilà je m'en fous un mais je le
ferai on est très attaché depuis deux
ans et c'est là que ça a été toujours
qu'avec le temps qui passe bah en fait
la réconciliation ça sera un jour sur un
lit d'hôpital sans indiscrétion pourquoi
tu étais fâché que ton papa c'est la
côte d'ivoire sait que c'est compliqué
moi j'ai perdu ma mère l'a longtemps et
puis c'est c'est pour des histoires de
famille de bêtises de et il a un
caractère c'est un peu toi et moi il a
son caractère moi aussi et puis leurs
yeux parce que c'est mon père et puis
moi aussi et on n'a jamais reçu un texto
en deux en tulle m bah évidemment et
puis vieilli là il a un certain âge et
put a qu'une trouille sais qu'un jour tu
es un coup de téléphone qui est enfin
voilà le temps passe c'est comme on dit
comment commence à vieillir en général
les réunions de famille c'est toujours
lors d'un attentat mandatant normand
houde en ville à vélo dans vie de
l'appeler tu as envie de prendre ces
nouvelles ou tu t'en en tous les cas
quand tu es seul chez toi comme je le
suis et comme beaucoup de gens de
l'évêché le quand tu es seul chez toi
que tu fais un peu le point et que tu te
rends compte que tu n'as coups bas tu
parles plus urgents tu parles plus ta
boîte parce que tu avais mais ta boîte
tu parles plus de ta voiture et de tout
ce qui est futile et que tu te
concentres sur vraiment l'essentiel
bah tu te rends compte que l'essentiel
c'est comme la famille les gens que tu
aimes et là tu te dis effectivement j'ai
tout raté quelque chose oui je pense que
ça devrait j'espère que ça fera
réfléchir autant que ça me fait
réfléchir
tu as tu va l'appeler je pense tu
attends tu attends qui t'appelle où tu
va l'appeler toi ça toi de la pire je te
lis à toi d'appeler ton papa pourquoi
ben tu vas y résonne comme toi il part
du principe que je suis fils donc ça va
devenir mardi à temps il ya déjà il ya
un respect de l'âge mais voilà c'est
toujours aux plus jeunes mais ils n'ont
rien d'appeler puis sait-on pas passer
ton père ton père tu dois l'appeler
c'est ton père tu dois tu doit pas
rester surtout dans une situation comme
celle-là je vous le dis et je le dis à
tous ceux qui nous regardent
franchement là on doit être tous
ensemble on doit être main dans la main
on doit tous se voient là elle je veux
plus la lande et plus dans un dans un 2
2 on est fâché on n'est pas fâchés on
est tous ensemble pour essayer de s'en
sortir
comment nous accompagne tous les jours
mais demain jour une nouvelle tenue vous
avez choisi le jogging
ok et où tu te enquêtes paranormales
n'oublie pas la télé c'est que la c